what's up you guys
it's movie retrospective time yeah and i
got a drink from last night
i've got a [ __ ] new refrigerator
upstairs a new ice maker upstairs so you
know if i don't ever if i don't finish a
trick i just i could put it in there i
don't have to go downstairs or anything
i'm like a king
[Laughter]
and then wake up the next morning and
put dice in it
you're like oh a little hair of the dog
cute
party ice machine this is the party ice
machine
maybe we might have a little bit of a
drinking problem
that's okay uh yeah we're just having a
good time all right so uh go back to the
1970s 1970s monster movie for this one
this is one that i saw
as a kid i didn't see it in the theater
but i think i saw it on cable like in
the early 80s i want to say and i
remembered it specifically because
stephen king talked about it in dance
macabre which i've read like a zillion
times
when he was kind of talking about a lot
of 70s eco horror so when this popped up
on hulu a couple weeks back i was like
oh we got to put that in the poll and it
won like handily like yeah it was like
all the boats the first time i saw this
thing is i saw
a damn
tv trailer or a trailer on tv for the
movie to be played
and there's a little clip of this
[ __ ] boy hopping away in a damn
sleeping bag and boom he goes flying and
hits a damn tree or a rock or something
explodes in a bunch of feathers he was
screaming running from that [ __ ] bear
and during that time
i was a little kid my aunt lois [ __ ]
my aunts and [ __ ] they were taking me up
to the sequoia national [ __ ] forest
up in the redwood forest so it looked
just like that place
every time i'd go there and i was
i saw that right before i went so the
whole time i was up there was [ __ ]
man i was didn't want to i didn't want
to shut the sleeping bag all the way
get out yes i could get out but
this and then like a couple months later
maybe around that same time maybe before
or after i don't know they were showing
clips that the photograph stills of this
thing in fangoria magazine
that [ __ ] was on the newsstand my cousin
wesley was buying for fangoria and it
was this movie scared scared me
and i didn't see it until later but just
no one of its existence scared me
started seeing the trailer and the fit
and and the pictures
uh in fact in fangoria magazine and um
i i did see it eventually anyway this is
before this is before alien one had come
out
or right around the same time i kind of
feel it was the same year this came out
this is prophecy by the way and it came
out in 1979 the way i remember it just
came out first it might have that's how
i remembered it because
it maybe it didn't but i remember this
one coming out first
an alien sucking all the damn
air out of the room this
i remember this movie being real popular
adults talking about it or teenagers
talking about they're probably teenagers
to me they look like adults
they were talking about how great it was
but then
then it vanished and all they were only
talking about alien then i saw alien my
dad took me to see alien
and alien [ __ ]
topped it all blew it away uh well i
mean yeah i mean alien kind of came on
the scene and ever all the other movies
were like well [ __ ] yeah
sometimes later i was i was able to
catch this movie i never saw in the
theater i think i saw it on vhs and uh
wasn't too impressed with it that was my
uh original memory of it but we watched
it again last night and um it was good
it was restored yeah it looks really
nice uh so if you have hulu you can
watch it on there you can probably watch
it on other streaming services too but
that was like one of the reasons that i
wanted to re-watch it because i hadn't
seen it since i was a kid and i
remembered it being like kind of cool
like kind of just like a big stupid like
70s eco-terror monster
yeah something like that um
but i had forgotten how entertaining it
was yeah uh just i don't know i kind of
feel like maybe even people that like
this movie are talking about you know
how stupid it is and stuff but
i don't even know if it's like stupid
it's just i don't know there's something
like really entertaining it's not even
all that cheesy really
um mercury gets in the water makes me
yeah mutant creatures one of them's a
big old bear the native americans think
it's one it's one of the native
americans who's who's like their
chieftain or magic man he thinks it's
the return of an indian god
and he's my favorite indian
he's my favorite yeah man the older guy
i think his name is uh mariah yeah the
first time i've seen him in this movie
they go that's my favorite indian right
there i give him a baby that's a [ __ ]
badass shot where he's watching uh the
[ __ ]
burning [ __ ] car or wasn't it burning
car that he was looking there's a car or
a cabin i can't remember because like
the man bear pig come in there it's like
oh yeah the man bear pig
and he's sitting there with his
sunglasses on us oh man old indian guy
and he see the [ __ ] burn the the
reflection of the bird and [ __ ] his
glasses looks like he had flaming eyes
and it was just kind of like the idea of
this thing was possessing him and he
already had mercury poisoning himself he
was crazy
you know oh yeah guy was crazy it's a
great character though like like the
movie man it's pretty neat it's retro
everything about 70s disaster flicks and
monster movies it's represented in this
movie and as i said it's yeah it's kind
of one of those nature run amok ones
where you know we're [ __ ] with the
environment and so the environment's
going to come back and like whip our
asses for us
in the form of like a big giant man bear
pig i kind of wonder if now that i'm
seeing it again if that's where the idea
for man bear pig came from i don't know
because it this definitely does look
like a man bear pig it's a big old
bipedal bear probably about 15 feet tall
yeah i think he's supposed to be 20 feet
at least according to what i read but
okay it's big it's it's a big it doesn't
have much hair on it it's pretty [ __ ]
distorted looking and it's and it's
having cubs and [ __ ] they find the cubs
and they look like
and they try to take care of the cubs
they eventually drown the cub like
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
well it did try to eat taliashire's face
yeah the cub was cool until it saw this
mama and then it remembered it was a
bear i guess it started attacking
everybody yeah [ __ ] these humans
yeah
you did this to me had talia in there
that's that's the same uh actress who
played uh adrian from from rocky from
rocky yeah yeah she was looking cute in
it that she's like the uh she's the
italian barbara eden
she looked a lot like barbie eating if
you were to make her give her blonde
hair i was talking about it
last night it says you know she looks
like barbara eden but they have her
always have a real plane they try to
make her look played and that one's
gorgeous
that's what like makes me laugh because
i kind of feel like they did that to her
in the rocky movies like she's i don't
know if they i don't remember if they
said this outright but i think they
tried to make her kind of homely and i'm
like she totally isn't yeah so i just i
don't know no you could do that to
barbara eating and get the same effect
yeah they just had fancy hair and
clothes
you and your fancy hair fancy ass hair
i was gonna say when we were talking
about the the monster in this
uh do you know who it was in that suit
it was um kevin peter hall the same guy
that was in the predator suit okay yeah
that really really all that dude yeah he
died young yeah died of cancer uh no he
was eight aids edward was eight yeah he
got he was actually he was in a car
accident got a transparent and he got a
transfusion and he got aids and he died
he was 36. yeah uh he was yeah but he
was in the first two predators
everybody said he was a great guy
because he was what like six foot eight
or six but nine like he was like
ridiculously yeah he was a clown did you
get on there and clown around all the
time he was harry and harry and the
hendersons too yeah yeah like the big
sasquatch monster he was in like a lot
of stuff like that but uh yeah that's a
strong movie a lot of strong uh strong
practical effects
for the time yeah for its time and uh
budget was good edit was good good score
good acting story was pretty good
i mean
sure i mean as i said but you know in
the 70s they had a lot of these
eco-terror you know nature run amok
things and most of them were
you know environmentalist kind of
messages it's a little heavy-handed with
that but i thought i don't know like a
lot of them were it didn't really bother
me all that much a lot of the indians
were
were italian
well italian indians
armand assante yeah play is kind of like
the main native american guy yeah john
hawks and i'm like oh there's the
storied hollywood tradition of italians
playing native americans and here we
have it again i'm not sure about the
other actors but yeah he's for sure he's
just like random people
yeah italians and mexicans
isn't that sad uh yeah a lot easier to
get a hold of i guess i mean i'm glad
they did they're trying to like not try
that so much anymore but yeah they did
do that a lot back then this was
actually directed by john frankenheimer
now this was the only
horror movie that he did
um he was more of a political thriller
type of guy like he did manchurian
candidate he did french connection too
he did birdman of alcatraz reindeer
games i think he did ronan which is a
great movie uh and he just wanted to
take a swing at a horror movie but
he didn't really like how this one
turned out he said well he uh was having
a lot of problems with alcoholism around
this time and he like kind of attributes
it to that maybe he was kind of drunk or
hungover or whatever and he's like it
didn't really come out the way he wanted
it wasn't real financially successful
either
um so it kind of disappeared but i i
feel like it did kind of get
you know some life in it later like on
cable and stuff and the guy that wrote
the screenplay for this was the same guy
that wrote the screenplay for the omen
the first one
uh you know david seltzer his name is
and uh so yeah so the story behind this
you got a couple
who the the husband is
he's a doctor right and he works in some
unnamed big city i'm assuming it's
supposed to be new york city or chicago
or wherever i don't know they didn't say
where it was but he uh he kind of works
with uh you know poor disadvantaged and
uh like i saw this one review that
called him the ghetto doctors
yeah so uh you know there was kind of a
thing during the 70s where there was the
tenement buildings and the babies were
like getting bitten by rats and all this
other stuff so he's going in there like
trying to sort that problem out but he's
getting real disillusioned because
he's like look it's like this i i try to
do something about it i try to fix it i
try to sue the landlord for having these
conditions and stuff and nothing happens
like nothing changes and i just feel
like i'm hitting my head against you the
city was all corrupt yeah and it's not
so it's just kind of like so he's
getting really like bummed out yeah
meanwhile his wife talia shire who is
she's like a
cellist right she's like a concert
cellist
and um she is pregnant
but she doesn't want to tell him that
she's pregnant because he's kind of like
we're not bringing any children into
this horrible world type of person
uh so she's really stressing out that
she's gonna have to tell him so yeah so
the doctor around this time me and jenny
are discussing his perm yeah yeah
well i was like well he first comes out
i'm like is he's played by robert
foxworth and i said oh my god he looks
like a bg and then i was like oh wait
everybody in the 70s looked like a beach
yeah even my dad's friends [ __ ] them
roll rednecks back in mississippi were
getting perms and then they'd let the
back grow so then they'd start getting a
little bit of a mullet perm that was a
futuristic
futuristic
mullet and then you realize that [ __ ]
that's the same that's the same um
uh basically the same haircut rick's
[ __ ] uh oh oh [ __ ] rick james had
they had nick james here
so it's just funny time man
[Laughter]
well i said yeah if you if you have the
perm and then you grow the back out you
look like one of the oak ridge
boys yeah
and really the hair from oakridge boys
and rick james it was the same hair it
was the same haircut basically
pretty yeah james just put some beads in
it yeah sometimes
but yeah so so the husband and wife um
you know this guy comes to the doctor
and uh what's like dr vern i guess his
name is and uh so somebody comes and
says okay well you need to get away we
need a doctor to come up like you need
to do like two weeks of work for the epa
because up in maine they're having this
dispute between a try like a native
american tribe who says this land is
theirs and a logging company or a paper
mill uh who say it's their land so you
know the native americans are like
blockading the place and not letting
them cut any trees down and blah blah so
this doctor is supposed to come and
sort of i guess he's
kind of gonna
talk everybody i don't really know and
they wanted him to do like some testing
around the water and everything because
some of the native americans were saying
you know the paper moles polluting the
water
so he goes up to go up to this uh cabin
and right away there's like some tension
between when they're trying to get up to
the cabin and then like the native
americans including john hawks who's
armand asante and you know some other
ones and they have this road chained off
and uh
somehow
it ends up in a chainsaw versus axe
fight
as as happens uh sometimes
so that kind of gets resolved it's kind
of a good fight it was actually do you
understand
how ridiculous this [ __ ] was
dude was getting ready to [ __ ] hit to
do with the chainsaw
over the fence yeah [ __ ] open open
the fence
[ __ ] stupid
the indians don't want to cut the trees
down you're gonna say no we're gonna cut
some trees down we're gonna start right
now just got one dude with a chainsaw
you know
kind of like the paper thrown nuts
around yeah the kind of like the paper
mill company doesn't have whole armies
of vehicles that can snip a tree in half
in a single [ __ ] you ever seen that
oh they're trying yeah but i guess they
were trying to like make a point i had
to make a point i guess i feel like they
were trying to i'm in mississippi
[ __ ] we have the masonite corporation
and just a couple of vehicles can cut
down about 100 trees in a day
and it just got a thing called i think
we call a skidder or a scooter i don't
[ __ ] it run up and grab the tree
around the base and the bottom of it had
snippers and it's like
like that and then then the vehicle
would move off with the damp tree
and throw them in the pile and they had
other vehicles that dragged the whole
pile they processed 100 trees in a day
and then they come back plant 150 trees
the next day right there in that spot
then 10 years later they cut them all
down together there's not a single
natural tree in mississippi all planted
[Laughter]
i should say too that
not only is this paper mill trying to
like encroach on these people's land but
they're also blaming the native
americans for a series of disappearances
that have been taking place in this area
which you know you me and everyone else
knows are the monster is doing it but of
course nobody else knows that so the
paper mill is just saying these native
americans they're so violent and they're
like they're killing people and all
these people are going missing and blah
blah they're blaming him for that uh but
no the native americans are pretty much
like uh no there's kind of this monster
in the world they call it katahdin right
that's what his name was yeah
and it's this big monster and it's
i don't even know if they called it like
a monster it was kind of like a spirit
of the forest spirit of the forest it
had every animal was inside of it and it
was it was one of the force basically is
what they're saying yeah every creature
that's there has a place in qatar and
so the the general description of
katahdin really is a mutant
yeah you could say yeah which is what it
is right it's all just all creatures
together all the life force of the the
forest together in one godlike creature
that's huge and comes back and kicks
your [ __ ] ass that's what katana was
so when they see this damn bear that
indian shaman because yeah that's it
that's katahdin i told you guys he was
out yeah now he was fun he was [ __ ] up
on mercury
too uh i mean he would smoke his
cigarettes down into his fingers his
fingers were all burned up where he
because he didn't have any sensations
and he was he was loopy you know but
once he saw katahd and that was it and
then in the end he kind of sacrificed
himself to katahdin
yeah and basically what happened to him
eventually
it's good he had a good death though i
guess he kind of acted as a speed bump
and kind of picked him up
he tried to stop qatad and he sacrificed
himself to cataract or he just kind of
stood there looking at it and i was like
does he think that katahdin is going to
be his butt or what no i think he was
just not running from it because it was
destiny that katahdin was pissed and
that he was going to itchy anyway so he
just stood there and it flipped his ass
up and slowed katahdin down for a few
seconds so that other people could get
away yeah i don't think it made a
difference though it looked like
katahdin could move pretty fast and it
could swim underneath the water like a
submarine kill it like a shark
yeah it was like jaws
he's a sneaky monster
he's sneaky though it's a great movie
you know it's cheesy but it's 70s it's
70. well like i said it's cheesy in a
70s kind of way but it's really really
entertaining i mean i think it's
entertaining yeah so it's a disaster
movie kind of like airport or something
airport 77 and all that [ __ ] happening
at once actually it most reminded me of
piranha
has mutants too
yeah it was also mutant mutant piranhas
well the thing about it though is that
it's not just i mean what you find out
like during the course of the you know
the doctor's investigation is that even
though the paper mill they even take
them like on a tour of the plant and
everything like that and they're like no
we don't pour anything because yeah they
bleach the paper with chlorine and all
this other stuff no nothing goes into
the water i'm like man i don't think
that's true but
and the guy who played she's talking
about who who's runs the paper mill is
the same dude who played i believe it
was the doctor in the thing
yeah he was also in this yeah i think he
was the one that he's got
he was giving the electoral shock yeah
wasn't that him no no it wasn't him
how did he die in the thing i can't
remember but he was definitely an older
guy yeah he's definitely in it not not
diabetes not that not diabetes not that
guy no the other guy yeah you'll
recognize him when you see him yeah he
was in a bunch of horror movies yeah he
plays like the manager of the plant or
whatever yeah
yeah so it's a good job he's actually
this is like he's like a main character
and
he's got a
uh
he does a good job as a lead
so he you know i mean his acting is good
it's the best it's the biggest role i've
seen him in yeah yeah
um but yeah so
i'm guessing now i think he is actually
maybe telling the truth about them not
dumping the chlorine and stuff into the
water because i don't think they find
that because the doctor does actually go
and like take water samples and stuff
but
what they do find out he's like yeah but
uh some of the stuff that i've seen
around the village like i said uh with
mariah like not having any feeling in
his fingers and being kind of crazy um
and he also sees some other [ __ ] like he
sees a salmon in the pond that's like
really [ __ ] big that's like big
enough to eat a duck hole uh so there's
that and uh also a lot of the native
americans are saying like you know a lot
of the babies were born with birth
defects and stuff so yeah
so yeah so he suspects that it's
probably mercury he's like because that
wouldn't come out in the water test
because mercury is heavier than water
and he does see something like on
taliashire's shoes and is like yeah that
looks like mercury and so
they don't find that out until later and
they've been at the cabin for a little
while
and talia shire has still not told her
husband that she's pregnant and in the
meantime they've eaten fish that he
caught out of that lake
and you know i don't know if you guys
know but mercury does actually cause uh
birth defects and it doesn't take much
either
so she is like now flipping out because
she doesn't know if she's gonna give
birth to a mutant or something this
story was actually based on a real thing
that happened in japan in 1958 i think
there was like it was some i don't know
if it was a paper mill but it was some
company that was like dumping
mercury and wastewater and and if this
whole village like that all the people
were like deformed yeah it killed a
hundred thousand people yeah it was like
a lot of a lot of people yeah the movie
this movie also points out that their
their head that it was illegal to
use mercury and and and dump mercury
into the environment in the u.s back in
even back in the 50s they knew the ship
was dangerous yeah mercury
there's a lot of [ __ ] that's bad
but mercury's right there with some of
the other heavy metals you don't you
don't you don't want to [ __ ] with it you
know it's not as bad as uranium but
it can be you know radon gas
uranium mercury
if it gets into you your your kidneys
can't get it out and so it just [ __ ]
you up
yeah you know
so yeah so they lead also so basically
what they're what they were doing is
that the paper mill when they would cut
the logs i guess they were treating the
logs with mercury like as a to kill the
fungus on it or whatever um and that was
leaching into the water and it was
leaching into this water like right by
the native americans village which was
causing all the birth defects and
everything like that um you know so they
you know there's [ __ ] big giant
tadpoles in there and obviously
the size of like a football and yeah and
then like i said the salmon that he saw
was like dolphin-sized you know what i
mean it ate a duck so there was that
which that kind of brought it to me
because uh you know going up to the
redwood forest they had [ __ ] big ass
[ __ ] we call them pollywogs yeah and
uh sometime pollywogs were
you know the size of an egg with a tail
on it that's that's as big as i've ever
seen them and you could get down the
water as a little kid and they'd be all
swimming around you
they'd be nibbling at you and [ __ ]
trying to get away they're in real
shallow warm waters where they'd like to
go
and so kids could get down in there and
[ __ ] play with the pollywogs those
[ __ ] were big some of them had little
back legs
some of them would look a little bit
more like frogs depending on their
development they were fun to play with
they were i wonder if the pollywogs felt
the same they're like oh no the big
giant
oh my god
the
big giant the big giant gods are picking
up yeah they were doing something nasty
in there because you'd come out of that
water stinking so you'd have to go into
[ __ ] deeper water obviously yeah you
had to get out of deeper water and get
it all off you adults go back man you
smell like them thanks you know yeah
okay and you get down there and [ __ ]
red socks
smell like tadpole
tadpoles maybe they were mating in there
they're probably too young to mate oh
yeah that's like that they're just
eating stuff that pulled child [ __ ]
and stuff
passing well that's all
the fish and frogs and stuff they stayed
in a big old school up in [ __ ] real
shallow water up around the bank
yeah yeah they like to warm if the water
was warm you knew they were in there
they just
they're trying to get away from you i
remember those we used to catch your
buckets and like watch them turn into
froggies yeah but uh but yeah so
so this big
uh
bear it's essentially i think
the design on the poster like if you see
the poster that kind of looks like a i
guess it's supposed to be a womb or like
an egg type situation and that has the
monster in it i think the original
monster design looked more like that but
when they went to make the movie they
went with more of a bear design it's it
looks like a mutated bear but it still
mostly looks like a bear except kind of
a man
yeah well yeah i know it's shaped it was
bipedal yeah it didn't run on four legs
that i saw
i mean i thought the practical effects
were pretty good i mean for for 1979 i
think the monster looks pretty good yeah
uh and honestly for this being a pg
movie uh
it's not super gory but it does have
some gory [ __ ] like one like the
helicopter pilot gets his head bitten
off yeah it doesn't show a bite they
don't show yeah he they just show like
him like the the back of the
monster the monster coming
leaves and the head's gone and then they
make like a crunching sound effect that
was delightful very effective and then
like the little kid hopping away in the
damn
i'm gonna i'm gonna put this
i'm gonna put this
you
yeah like a boulder and he goes boom and
it explodes and feathers and [ __ ] they
come down
i'm totally putting that though i would
not sleep with that damn sleeping bag
all the way zipped up by sleeping about
a little that way i could jump out if i
had to that that got me thinking because
he was trying to hop away even
even though seeing it now it's hilarious
i had completely forgotten about this i
mean it's a little kid i always kind of
like when horror movies have the stones
to like kill off a little kid yeah uh
like it especially in such a
ridiculously over-the-top way is that i
was like awesome people at the same age
as me but i
like the kid exploded i'm on the menu
man
yeah that's what i mean that's why i
like that's why i like that horror
movies
that will go there because that's gonna
be way scarier to a kid it's like
because you think i always think kids
are kind of like safe you know like in
horror movies and on this time he'd he
blew up pretty much yeah we were talking
about earlier this is the same when i
was watching that 1950s war the world
with that preacher going out there
trying to talk to the aliens and he's
praying you know
[Laughter]
yeah seriously when i had totally
forgotten about the kid in the sleeping
bag scene from prophecy so when we were
watching it again we watched it last
night and i died laughing i just laid it
back
and cracked it but i was like we got to
watch that i guess
yeah and i was like i just like laughed
and laughed and left oh my god it was so
[ __ ] funny that's i think that has to
be one of the best movie deaths yeah of
all time that's even better than the one
from friday the 13th part 7 where
somebody got picked up in a sleeping bag
and jason slammed him against a tree
this ends way better this is the
original i mean yeah this is like the og
of that so yeah that's like [ __ ] it's
great the kids hopping and the bear
comes up and just goes back
and he goes [ __ ] flying and it's not
a slow fly it's like shot like a damn
like a hockey puck
it's so good yeah he hits and the
[ __ ] sleeping bed explodes
you could tell they had a squib brownie
yeah
it's one of the funniest things about
went off it was one of the funniest
things i've ever seen
i was like a child
i mean it's a movie come on
but yeah i mean the the helicopter
probably get his head bit off is pretty
good too but that was a lot more low-key
uh and i did enjoy i did enjoy the
monster like shaking your favorite
indian around that was also pretty funny
although that was like pretty brief but
nothing could top that sleeping bag i
mean that was like so [ __ ] hilarious
but uh but yeah so
uh you know this actually because you
were asking where this was shot it's
actually it's supposed to be maine yeah
uh they actually shot in british
columbia okay and
interestingly
this was the first you know how nowadays
even now uh they film a lot of movies in
canada because it's cheaper
uh this was pretty much the first movie
to do that um you know where taking
advantage of it being cheaper up there
and now they call it like hollywood
north or whatever uh you know filming
stuff up there and this was kind of like
the first one to do that although like i
said
i kind of feel like this didn't really
do
very well like at the box office and it
does have a lot of
fans but a lot of the reviews
from the time um you know the
contemporary reviews thought that it was
like just kind of stupid
uh stupid and boring but i kind of feel
like people have developed more of an
appreciation for it i wouldn't even call
it i don't even think it's like so bad
it's good i think it's like a decent
movie it's a movie of its time very
standard yeah it's like a standard 70s
movie it's got a good monster yeah um
you know i think the monster looks good
and you know it's got
i i honestly found most of the
characters really interesting yeah the
reason why they were saying it was
boring is because it's a movie of its
time a lot of other movies from that
time felt like this
so yeah he's kind of bored with this and
when alien came out it would have just
totally erased this yeah that's true the
same way that
same way that logan's run was totally
erased by star wars when star wars came
out that was it logan's run was quickly
forgotten yeah yeah probably the same
was good when it came out for a few
months and then star wars came out now
you never heard about logan's run again
but it's a cult classic now
yeah you know logan's right well i do
kind of like you know sometimes like you
said with some movies come out like the
timing is bad yeah um and it doesn't
mean that the movie is not any good it
just means that you know everybody was
distracted by this other object over
here so same thing with logan's run
television series i have it on on dvd
it's a great television series a lot of
the same people that worked on the old
star trek did it it's just that no that
could never exist in a world where there
was star wars
yeah that was that was the end of that
but yeah so i think that went for what
two seasons
yeah and then that was it yeah and then
um but yeah this movie was actually
like i said it's pg because they didn't
have pg-13 until the until the 80s uh so
it's not real graphic it there was a
couple scenes in it that were a lot
gorier
like i think like the guy from the thing
you know he uh he basically gets torn in
half by the bear although they don't
really show it it's just like implied
yeah in the original cut they did
actually show like he was getting
disemboweled oh man um
i don't know i kind of feel like i mean
they shot it and then john frank and i
was like man you know he thought it was
like too much like over the top little
did they know uh yeah
i was just kind of like they and there
was also a shot too i don't know if they
necessarily did it for readings i think
they just thought it was you know the
directors thought it was too much and
there was also like more of a close-up
shot of you know the helicopter pilot
they got his head bit off yeah i think
they went in more for like a close
because it's a little bit it's not a
long shot but it's kind of like middle
well they [ __ ] they [ __ ] up by
wanting a pg rating but maybe maybe i
don't know maybe the market at the time
the market of that day pg was the way to
go because adults were kind of sick of
these kind of movies probably by the
time this came out yeah and then
but you know [ __ ] having some [ __ ]
with it was real graphic and scary like
[ __ ]
alien that worked yeah you know
but they don't they didn't know though
yeah it's you know hindsight's 20 20. so
i kind of wish they'd left the gory [ __ ]
in there yeah a lot better but you know
it's still got like some decent gore in
it and like i said it's got good actors
in it and i thought the you know i liked
all the kind of uh you know character
interactions all the characters were
good all the acting was good um only
thing
i
the ending
it's not really left ambiguous because
it's like they kill you know the main
man bear pig right but then like there's
a little reveal
at the end there's another one which i
presume is the dad
of the yeah the cubs that they got yeah
because it hadn't hit cubs so there
hadn't been a man so there hadn't been a
male somewhere so yeah but they never
tell you do they if talia shire's baby
and it's like turned out normal well
they were trying to make a damn
probably set it up for a sequel
you know because it's alive was around
already that's right they're they're
kind of hinting on the fact that maybe
her baby might be something like it's
alive that's going to eat its way out of
their room this is the bear version of
it's alive
yeah it kind of is that's all that's
what it is if you guys haven't seen it
it's alive it's the amazing that's the
killer baby movie yeah this is the this
is the bear version of that yeah so that
was the thing because we were watching
it and then like at the end i was like
is there a scene at the end where talia
shire gives birth to say it's like oh my
god and then the credits run but they
never tell you like the end is just like
them jumping in their plane and getting
the [ __ ] out of dodge and i was like so
we never find out like if she had a
meeting baby or nothing
i guess it doesn't matter so you'll
never find you were sick of the movie by
the time
that's what they were doing
this movie is actually it's better than
i remember yeah it's all right it's
pretty it's pretty entertaining i found
it pretty entertaining uh if only just
it's worth the price of admission just
for that [ __ ] sleeping bag scene
which is one of the funniest things that
i've ever seen in my whole entire life
yeah um but yeah good monster good
acting it's fun uh if you have hulu it's
on there right now uh if you want to go
check it out or i'm sure you can find it
under other streaming services as well
uh so yeah if you like [ __ ] 70s
nature run amok monster movies then you
gotta see it man it's pretty [ __ ]
good
alright so that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you guys on
the next one bye